with the release of the Apple 2e
personal computing for everyone is no
longer the stuff of science fiction
that's right kids you can write a paper
on it for your high school English class
crank up the Led Zeppelin and knock out
a killer draft the e stands for enhanced
now with 64 kilobytes of RAM and basic
programming language built into the
firmware Apple is giving the Commodore
64 a real run for its money here it is
the industry benchmark 80 columns of
text and the Apple 2e also features
lowercase letters and this machine can
take up to two five and a quarter inch
floppy disks at the same time with sleek
elegant design Wozniak and Jobs have
more than delivered on the promise of
their Apple - these guys may have a very
bright future ahead buy some Apple stock
I got a real hunch that it's gonna pay
off
send us pictures of your favorite retro
gadgets in the comments and please
subscribe to the wired Channel
you